THAT WILL BE A SHAME IF AN
AGREEMENT IS NOT REACHED WITH
NORTH KOREA.
CORRESPONDENT RICH ADMIN IS AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
STORY TONIGHT.
>> THEY MADE REAL PROGRESS, THAT
IS A REPORT FROM SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO FOLLOWING
HOURS OF MEETINGS THIS MORNING
AND LAST NIGHT WITH NORTH KOREAN
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> THERE IS NOTHING SHORT OF
TRAGIC TO LET THE OPPORTUNITY GO
TO WASTE.
>> THEY SPENT DECADES BUILDING A
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM TO
SAFEGUARD ITS REGIME.
SECRETARY POMPEO SAYS THAT HIS
MISSION IS TO CONVINCE KIM
JONG UN THAT HIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
ACTUALLY PRESENT A THREAT TO HIS
SECURITY.
NOT PROTECTION.
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP AGREED TO
A SUMMONS WITH KIM JONG UN, THE
RHETORIC BETWEEN THE COUNTRIES
HAS ESCALATED BETWEEN
THREATENING AND COMPLEMENTARY.
>> WE WILL NOT BE SURPRISED OR
FRIGHTENED OR DETERRED BY
MOMENTS WHERE IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND
DIFFICULTIES.
THINGS THAT CANNOT BE BRIDGED.
OUR MISSION IS TO BRIDGE THEM.
>> ONE WEEK AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP RELEASED A
LETTER TO KIM JONG UN, CANCELING
THE JUNE 12TH CEMENT, THE TOP
EMBASSY AREAS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
CARRYING A LETTER FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
POMPEO SAYS THAT KIM JONG CHUL
WILL DELIVER IN WASHINGTON.
IT TESTIFIES WHAT IS A
WILLINGNESS TO DISMANTLE THE
PROGRAM.
NOW THE MIDDLE BARRY INSTITUTE
FOR INTERNATIONAL STUDY MEG
STUDY SAYS THAT NORTH KOREA IS
REMOVING MATERIAL FROM THE SITE
SO I'M SITE BEFORE THE
DESTRUCTION.
A CONFERENCE TO FOX NEWS THAT
"THE NORTH KOREANS ARE STILL
TREATING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM AS
SENSITIVE.
THAT SUGGEST THAT NORTH KOREA IS
UNLIKELY TO HAND OVER HER ACTUAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS" WHILE HIS
VICE CHAIRMAN IS UNITED STATES,
KIM JONG UN HOSTED SERGEY LAVROV
WHO DELIVERED A GREETING FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> HE SENDS HIS WARMEST REGARDS
AND BEST WISHES THAT HAVE BEEN
INITIATED ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA WITH YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
>> AS A RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TRIES
TO INVOLVE ITSELF IN THE ISSUE,
HE ALSO INVITED CAME TO MOSCOW.
>> THE ORIGINAL DATE FOR THE
SUMMIT IS LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
AWAY.
JUNE 12TH, WHEN ASKED WHETHER IT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN ON THAT DATE,